actor Dane delegro sacrificed a lot of  Mobility for the role of predator in  prey conditions were challenging but fun  at the same time one of the biggest  problems was the 11 pound mechanical  head he had to wear he had to look down  in order for the Predator to be looking  forward and don't even try asking Dane a  question on set that headpiece was also  animatronic which produced a whole lot  of buzzing next on Dane's list of  problems was the heat the temperature on  set was in the 90s and during that  smokey scene he was hot disoriented and  couldn't even see anything never work  with smoke in a field because it was so  difficult pair that with a rubber suit  and heavy helmet and you've got an  actual Predator workout session